i'm gonna tell you what the cabinet
looks like right now
who they're looking at secretary state
we know the name susan rice
obama's national security adviser he won
susan rice second places
anthony blinken obama's former deputy
secretary of state
and deputy national security adviser
those are the names so far there's a few
other ones but those are the main ones
secretary of defense
michelle forney hillary is picking 2016.
oh i thought he'd go with captain crunch
or something
he's looking at them johnson obama's
department of homeland security head
attorney general sally yates okay career
federal prosecutor kelly yates is obese
she's the one who refused to defend
trump's executive order banning
travelers from several muslim
majority countries second one is senator
doug jones from alabama
secretary of treasury this is a scary
one elizabeth warren
first on the list it's very scary for
the industry you are a part of
the second is leo brainerd governor of
federal reserve okay
then you have secretary of homeland
security they have lisa monaco
obama's homeland security advisor or
alejandro
mayorkas former director of u.s
citizenship and immigration services
which that means
the whole thing could potentially open
up secretary of health and human
services governor michelle
lujan grisham new mexico governor or
karen bass congressional black caucus
leader secretary of labor julie sue
extremely progressive nominee former
california labor and workforce
development agency
this is not good news and secretary of
labor he's also looking at the one and
only legendary vermont senator
bernie sanders right right sanders
he's looking at something about the
department of
labor being ran by senders i'll give you
three more and then i'm going to turn it
over to you guys secretary education
lilly esquilen garcia former national
education association president and
current elementary school teacher
secretary of commerce meg whitman
secretary of energy ernest
moniz and elizabeth sherwood randall
both on obama's cabinet
monis is tied to fossil fuel so
progressives may not want to go that he
don't
they don't think he's far left enough
because moniz kind of wants fossil fuel
administrative environmental protection
agency mary nichols
queen of green i don't know if you know
who she is she's the california air
regulator
head of veteran affairs mayor pete
buddha that's the list what's his title
he's going to be potentially the
head of veteran affairs oh yeah that's
the list
did he have a military background
people like him by the way he's a very
well spoken guy he's on fox news every
day pretty much he's a very well spoken
guy you got to give him respect for
showing up on fox news
and i do yeah 100 i do yeah yeah 100
percent idea but he's like
he'll take the airwaves anywhere he can
yeah he's uh and he's very very eloquent
he's very well spoken so that's the list
that's what's going to happen
about the list aside from bernie sanders
elizabeth warren because i know you're
not fans of that oh
it's not about how i feel about the list
biden's committed to being the most
progressive president we've ever seen in
america including obama
that's what his commitment is he said
that his words his platform i will be
the most progressive
president and have the most progressive
cabinet we've ever had in america
and let's take it a couple steps further
he already has the most progressive
senator as his vice president
boom she's even more progressive than he
is they're getting
the the biggest fear i have is who are
who who are they getting their marching
orders from
is it all aoc and her crew and bernie
calling the shots i mean they are
they are not bashful either have you
noticed how bold they are
they're not real subtle in what they
want they want complete control
of that democratic party the other thing
when you look at those cabinet list
names
so many of those deals were already cut
during the primaries right a lot of
times these guys will bow out of the
primary for a favor down the road and
you know that elizabeth warren
bernie sanders bernie sanders i mean
with with the following the
that he has with young kids at gen x i
mean you know that there was something
promised to him
yeah so um they were all guaranteed this
you know it also shows the importance of
georgia
and just how big this really truly is
coming up in that revote
because like ted cruz flat out says hey
we can stop some of this in the first
year if we still control the senate if
not they are pushing
every one of these things and they'll
get their way and it'll all happen so
man george is huge you know there's i'm
sure we'll talk about georgia later but
man the amount of money that you're
going to see being poured into that
state in the next month and a half is
going to make your head spin
well i think we saw some numbers already
come out 200 million dollars is that
what the number there for what georgia
200 million dollars is what they're
thinking about spending
on uh those two seats and by the way you
know they spent 130 million dollars to
be
lindsey graham jamie harrison from south
carolina used
130 million dollars to build lindsey
graham and they lost lindsey graham
spent seventy
three dollars a vote jamie spent 118
dollars a vote and they still lost and
mcconnell against mcgrath
they spent for georgia 90 million
dollars ended up spending 75 million
dollars and still lost to mcconnell so
it's going to be interesting how much
money they spend
to win georgia i mean in order to win
south carolina
in order to win kentucky you can't
play it light like you got to go massive
with it and even then
spend spending that much money in south
carolina could they could not do it
you know so that's an uphill battle over
there you love analogies and you know i
think the founding fathers are just so
brilliant the way they set this country
up with three
branches you know you got the president
you got the house you got congress you
got the senate
because you don't want one party having
all the par
the power it's just not really good for
the country unless it's all republican
well you know what i'm down for what
makes the most sense for the country
and you know i don't i don't i think
having opposite
voices is healthy and very much needed i
think
if there you go tom if somehow the
senate
goes over to the democrat side this is
what it's going to be like it's it's
going to be like you have
teenagers right and you go on a a
month-long cruise and you leave them
your atm card
a stock liquor cabinet and all your guns
i mean that is
there's no one over there's like a party
to me they can do whatever the hell they
want
and that when i'm looking down the road
that's what i see
because they are not shy about telling
you what they want to do
and their end vision for this country is
nothing like
the country was set out to be and how
it's been for the most part of the last
240 years
[Music]